how many times have the 2020 Democrats
assured us that they don't actually
support the radical agenda of open
borders open borders just a right wing
talking point it always has been no I
don't support open borders we do have a
problem this other border Democrats
should not deny that we don't nations
should have borders were to be respected
in closing borders or NATO that's a coke
brothers proposal just like how they're
not socialist anti-american or anti law
enforcement they're not for open borders
you're the crazy people for thinking
that they told us all this with a
straight face but now the Democrat lies
laid bare in announcing a new rule on
family detentions keeping families
together President Trump is drawing out
the 2020 Democrats true radical nature
brilliant the new rule will end the
long-standing and absurd catch and
release approach that basically lets
illegal immigrants with children
disappear into the country's interior
and ultimately avoid ever having to go
before an immigration judge now families
under this new rule will be held
together in improvised housing while
they await their day in court and
children of course at the time will be
protected from human traffickers so
President Obama had separation I'm the
one that brought them together this new
rule will do even more to bring them
together but it was President Obama that
had the separation very much I have the
children on my mind it bothers me very
greatly reacting to this like moths to a
flame Democrats could not help but
reveal the open borders fanatics that
they truly are instead of working to
keep families together and with
unaccompanied minors for instance to
find them family members you know
usually they have family members who
live already in the United States to
find those family members quickly or to
find a sponsor who would take them into
a loving home okay there you go again
Castro is exposed right there first the
Trump administration's new rule in case
II can't act
here will keep families together that's
what Castro said he was so worried about
before once it's actually established
that they're actually related some of
them aren't now an anchor that actually
cared about the facts would have
interjected their second wholly and
Castro reveals the Democrats true agenda
all along a massive resettlement of
migrants most of whom have no valid
claims into the United States remember
this cost you more money crowds our
public schools and facilitates families
use of children to game the system
unless you think that majority of these
unaccompanied minors are toddlers here's
the actual factual breakdown from HHS in
fiscal year 2018 72% of those minors
were between the ages of fifteen and
seventeen years old and all told 84
percent were teenagers from the age of
13 to 17 years old 18 they become adults
now Democrats like Castro they love also
to talk about alternatives to detention
this is becoming catching on the
campaign trail so alternatives I'm gonna
translate that for you
release all border crossers even if
you're releasing them into the custody
of other illegals that's allowed now
into the law and if they don't ever show
up for their immigration hearings no
penalty and you know deportation not
gonna deport them now the Democrats
tedious refrain let's get to that about
kids and cages immigrants drinking from
toilets and babies rip from quote
lactating mothers turned out to be false
liberal media propaganda fake news
Trump's new rule and ending the 1997
Flores settlement will not just
discourage illegal immigration in bogus
asylum claims it will actually reduce
human trafficking and save lives
including the lives of all those people
that the Democrats claim they care about
migrant women and children but we were
thinking about this today we're all
talking about doing the segment and
sadly
those children are just collateral
collateral damage to the radical left
and so are the Americans maimed or
killed by open borders policies in
states and cities across the United
States just miles from here I know eight
nine miles officials in Montgomery
County Maryland declared sanctuary
status and refused future cooperation
with ice The Washington Post lauded the
move of course and the do-gooder
journalists they're not going to connect
the dots they're going to connect the
dots because not one for illegals in the
same County were arrested on rape
charges just in the last month one of
the accused a 26 year old Honduran
allegedly followed a woman to her car
threw her to the ground
strangled her and then raped her leaving
her for dead she nearly died well any
mainstream media outlets asked 20/20
Democrats about these alleged crimes
talk a lot about the kids in cages and
other concerns at the border but what
about Americans and immigrants in the
United States being brutalized not gonna
cover it a few weeks ago they tripped
over themselves emotionally manipulating
distraught immigrant children for a
political purpose
how many times did they use these
children on the air a lot but the
suffering of the woman and Maryland just
not worth a mention more human carnage
more collateral damage all the necessary
price to pay for the Utopia of a
borderless USA the left like clockwork
will run to the nearest activist judge
and no doubt California Supreme
Commander dolly gee who masquerades as
an impartial federal judge will rebuff
the Trump administration yet again with
this new rule her past rulings
demonstrate how out of control these
robed tyrants have become but regardless
of the legal outcome the president here
I think prevails politically his vision
for orderly merit-based immigration and
for managing the border wave is
pragmatic its compassion
and it upholds the rule of law the 2020
Democrats approach is unsustainable
reckless and can be deadly and that's
the angle